pendant la seconde vague la catalogne a
pris une batterie de mesures parmi elles
les centres commerciaux ont dû fermer
leurs portes
ainsi que les magasins de plus de 800
mètres carrés alors les grandes
boutiques ont pu rester ouverte mais en
réduisant leur espace à l'intérieur
la catalogne a décidé de favoriser les
petits commerces d'une part pour des
raisons économiques car selon les
associations de commerçants de barcelone
jusqu'à 50% des boutiques pourraient
fermer définitivement leurs portes d'ici
la fin de l'année
d'autre part pour des raisons sanitaires
car la catalogne estime que les mesures
de sécurité sont plus facilement à
contrôlable à l'intérieur des petits
espaces alors les commerçants ont déjà
beaucoup souffert du premier confinement
mais aussi de la mauvaise saison
touristique à barcelone il salue donc
cette mesure car une nouvelle fermeture
aurait été dramatique pour eux je vous
propose de les écouter
comme on l'a montré il y à toujours plus
de gens qui s'accumulent dans un grand
magasin que dans un petit magasin
et puis quand on donne sur la rue on
peut toujours dire attends un peu avant
d'entrer
on peut toujours contrôler davantage que
dans un grand magasin dans un grand
magasin les gens rentrent sans arrêt et
personne ne regarde qui entrent tous les
petits commerces de barcelone ne sont
pas en danger
mais quand même si on se balade dans la
rue on voit que beaucoup ont déjà fermé
beaucoup de locaux à louer mais personne
ne veut le prendre avec la situation
actuelle personne ne prend le risque
donc c'est un cercle vicieux
on verra si on peut l'arrêter
normalement nous les libraires nous
pourrons rester ouvert même s'il ya un
confinement
en principe nous ne serons pas obligés
de fermer mais on n'a pas trop confiance
non plus parce qu'ils ont déjà fait
fermer les cinémas et les théâtres mais
on nous a déclaré comme commerce
essentiel donc tout pourrions toujours
restés ouverts
par ailleurs la mairie de barcelone a
augmenté son budget des illuminations de
noël particulièrement dans les zones
touristiques
l'objectif est à nouveau d'attirer les
barcelonais pour les inciter à consommer
dans les établissements indépendants